alright guys bang bang I'm here with
Mike Novick rats thanks for jumping on
to do this so quickly on short notice my
friend hope we have some fun absolutely
yeah look I think one of the big things
right now people want to know is just
what's going on so how do you think
through given the fact you've lived
through so many of these you've traded
through so many how do you evaluate
what's going on on the global market
right now you know every once in a while
you know when it's happened I don't know
three or four times in my 25 30 year
trading career you get a category 7
hurricane where it becomes just global
risk off and the system goes through a
massive deleveraging and that's what
you're seeing right now it's usually you
know comes from intense insert
uncertainty sometimes it comes from
intense leverage this one I think is
really from intense uncertainty you know
with the the coronavirus and how it's
going to end up and I'm gonna never
really had economy going into complete
shutdown on a global scale almost like a
rolling blackout and so you know things
that it totally should make sense
necessarily don't because it's where
people have positions they are selling
them to get to cash and it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy and so you
think look like things like risk parity
which is being unwound at it an immense
pace and so the Bridgewater hedge fund
posted 20% down you know you know for
the year so far
it's worse drawdown I think in you know
20 years crypto which you know a lot of
people were talking you know Bitcoin and
I was a big advocate of Bitcoin as this
digital gold this hard money asset which
should do well when senator bikes flood
the world with liquid
when fiscal becomes irresponsible and
you know we just start opening up the
checkbook I mean that's exactly what's
happening yes it's a leverage risk asset
right we forget that it's still mostly
retail hell and a lot of retail buys on
leveraged out in you know bit Mex and
and finance and all the the the great
Asian exchanges / machine casinos and
you know people are having a hard time
they need to make their bills they're
losing money and other things they start
selling and you just have a rolling
snowball and new money is scared like
even if you have a ton of cash on the
sidelines you're in the middle of a
shitstorm and you're not going yeah let
me step it right now and buy some
Bitcoin which I've never bought before
and so you got some old hats that maybe
we're smart enough to sell it that are
buying some but you don't have a whole
lot of new honey coming in and you're
not gonna have new money come in for a
while and so I think as far as Kryptos
concerned you know this probably sets
the story the narrative of new adoption
in Bitcoin is a store of value or in the
other coins as part of the future of
building a centralized internet you know
it sets it back 12 to 18 months just you
can kind of tell because it's gonna
we're gonna have to get through this and
then you gotta rebuild confidence yeah
how do you think about kind of these
quote-unquote safe haven assets right so
you see gold the the treasury issues etc
forget crypto for a second but just when
we get to these D leverage points or
kind of these liquidity crisis do you
almost expect most of those assets to
get sold off as well or do you actually
expect them to hold up pretty well
during those liquidity crises I I think
another credit equation in a liquidity
crises anything people are long gonna
get sold and so people were max along
rolled and they're selling now you can
with hindsight look back and say well
this is one
greatest deflationary impulses we've
ever seen in our lives and so you're
going to go through a period of intense
deflation and crypto and goal we're
supposed to be inflation hedges and even
if they cut rates to zero and print
money and drop it out of helicopters can
they beat deflation which we've had a
hard time beating you know in Japan for
30 years now and the rest of the world
we're be trying and so you know we might
look back and say this moving gold and
this moving in Bitcoin wasn't as
irrational as it felt you won't know
until the dust settles I personally
think you're gonna have a brief period
of deflation and you're stoking the
fires for inflation because I think the
economies will come back faster than you
think
once we get through this flu god-willing
and and there's gonna be a ton of
liquidity and a real fiscal profit
profit legacy that we already had that's
now going to be exaggerated yeah and one
thing you start off by saying was kind
of this like rolling blackout of
economic activity because people are
being forced to stay inside it cetera
the thing to me that is kind of just
unprecedented is the fact that it's not
like people are spending a little less
money they literally are not leaving
their homes at all right they're just
being stuck in their homes and so do you
think that that's something where the
monetary stimulus plans etc can actually
stimulate economic activity or is it the
virus kind of has to be beaten if you
will before we can get any of that
economic activity back and the monetary
stimulus doesn't really matter so I
think listen I think the Fed did what
they're gonna do and they'll do war and
they're doing a great job
lots of liquidity they're gonna my guess
is the next step they'll come into the
commercial paper market there is no they
want to make sure there's no sand in the
gears but this is gonna take fiscal and
in some ways they set up minuchin and
Trump with the blessing of you know
Nancy Pelosi to open the checkbook
for it to ton and the Fed is going to
monetize their gonna basically monetize
the fiscal stimulus right you've got
zero rates in unlimited repos and so in
a lot of ways this should make yield
curves go steeper it should make the
dollar weakened it should make crypto go
higher over time but in the short run
what's gonna get the economy back isn't
monetary its fiscal and so we really got
to watch what the package that you know
again you know it's it's it's minuchin
lead minuchin trump but you know Pelosi
is gonna have to bless it that they get
through some of that they want to do the
macro the payroll tax cut there's a lot
of pressure to just put money into the
system I mean everybody rightfully
including myself is worried about you
know this gig economy that we have if
you're a Pilates instructor a yoga
instructor a delivery guy
well maybe delivery guys into alright
but a waiter a bartender you know all of
those jobs go to you know cash flow
negative real fast and they don't have
normal salaries and if you think about
forty percent of America has less than
four hundred dollars of savings you know
we go to three weeks of this forget not
paying your rent people are not gonna
have money for food and so there's a
fear of social unrest I mean I have
really smart rational friends who are
you know leaving the city buying 30 you
know 90 days worth of food and holding
up not because they're worried about the
virus because they're worried about
writing and I think that's a little
extreme honestly I think our social
safety structure is better than that and
that will have food available for people
and the authorities are already planning
on all this stuff but these are not
irrational guys these are smart
investors and so you can tell where fear
has gone what if you're in charge of
kind of this fiscal stimulus there's a
lot of people have come on and talked
about monetary stimulus but nobody's
really kind of hit hard on the fiscal
side what would you do or what do you
think should be done
there that could actually have an impact
listen there's there two angles that I
think I would do and I think the
administration actually is gonna do I
have rarely got on board with this
administration you read my Twitter but I
think in this case they they probably
are gonna end up you know stumbling into
the right the right movement I mean the
first is get money out quick and so the
most radical would be some form of ubi
for people that need it just you know
Hong Kong did it
I believe Australia is doing it where
you literally just cut checks to people
ask you boy that give people money so
they can buy their food so they can pay
their rent right just keep the economy
going you know you can do that with a
payroll tax as well on a broad scan the
second and I think the administration
was already playing this I mean one way
Trump was going to try to get reelected
is he is planning a massive massive
infrastructure build are at least prop
it's a prop and infrastructure build a
trillion dollar infrastructure bill he
wanted to originally unveil it right
around the Democratic convention as his
steal their thunder and you know ride
that into the election that wouldn't
surprise me if that gets you know
brought forward in its timeline and they
still push that so kind of on one hand
how do you get money into the system
quickly on the other hand how do you
actually start this big build where
those are big contracts that that get
put in place over time and you can see
at least people say hey these industrial
businesses aren't going to go out of
business they're gonna have [ __ ] to do
yeah but part of what I think is
interesting a lot of folks right now is
you know last week we spoke a lot about
kind of this monetary stimulus bomb
right it's almost like they brought like
a water gun to a combat zone to start
and then they had to come out with
something really big they did that fun
day but then you saw the market reaction
right obviously this morning hitting
circuit breakers in the stock market etc
is there anything that they can do on
the monetary side or is it only the
fiscal stuff you
think that will actually have an impact
and and kind of get accomplished with
the mantras that it kind always has an
impact
it always has an impact and so I would
say it on my son was supposed to go to
Jackson Hole for spring break skiing and
he was going with other family and so
they were gonna leave on Saturday but he
was supposed to take his SATs so they
decided to leave on Sunday and on
Saturday we were talking about it and a
BSA teens got cancelled but alright yeah
they're still going they're still going
they're still going even though they're
gonna maybe close one of the tram and
and it went from Sunday morning oh we're
not going to go because it looks like
they could close down to the mountain
being close to the hotel a on a piece of
literally being shuttered all in like a
24 hour period and so we went from
sending our kid to the whole mountain
being closed and I think there was a
psycho psychological shift this weekend
where Saturday night
New Orleans to Sunday people say no no
no no no no no no don't leave your
freaking house and so there was a
gigantic fear shift between Saturday and
Sunday that I saw salads and a wake-up
call I think where people finally got it
that translated into the market this
morning and I don't think anything the
Fed would have done you know would have
would have you know created a different
environment I do think we'll see how the
market closes today
you know sometimes that initial panic
has to happen we despite VIX to almost
80 you know Vic's at 80 doesn't stay up
there that often you know there's only
one other time I remember my career that
it was above 80 and that was o8 and so
we're getting close to panic and I think
that fender quiddity will help I do
still think there's more to do they need
to unlock unclog the commercial paper
market and they really need on the
fiscal side to speak to all these small
businesses I mean every single hotel in
America is going to go to zero
al-qaeda's here are some tiny occupancy
and so how do you how do you throw the
lifeline to businesses that need the to
money you know break and and then not
throw a lifeline to businesses that are
gonna go out of business no matter what
you do it's a tricky game no break and
and then not for a lifeline to
businesses that are gonna go out of
business no matter what you do and not
for a lifeline to businesses that are
gonna go out of business no matter what
you do alrighty I just heard myself oh I
think that uh Mike he still hear me if I
hear you and I just heard myself yeah so
maybe you can talk a little bit also
about in terms of the investor see what
do you think people should be thinking
through and and how should they be
looking at the various opportunities in
the market versus just the flight to
safety and get into cash
I think if you haven't gotten to cash
it's too late
like the could the stock market go lower
yet could the S&P S&P is at 2500 right
now or was when I walked into this
office could it go to 2200 it certainly
could so that's another 10% you know
little it's 88% I could go lower right
way to guess in here 8 to 10% that I
think would be the ultimate low if you
just look on the charts there's a lot of
support down there and so I would if I
was an investor a not take a lot of
leverage yet right we're still in a
danger zone but if there's a good time
to take a lot of leverage and I would
start looking at individual stories that
are so bummed out that you know it's a
good company that you know it's not
going out of business say that it's got
a good cash flow and you're buying it at
50 cents on the dollar versus where you
were you know two months ago and there
are lots of lots of individual stocks
one of my worries for crypto quite
frankly and as I look at my own money
you know I was I acted decently on the
macro side and slow on the crypto side
stubborn you know it's a core position
and so loved a lot of Bitcoin all the
way down and now I'm looking okay where
do you add there are so many individual
stock stories that you feel like even if
you get in it's a little early you know
in a few months there's no way you're
losing on this thing because they got
cash flow you're buying it at a discount
a big discount and so I think they're
probably easier investment opportunities
in the stock market then there are in
more speculative markets you know
speculative markets take a story they
take confidence I look back I want to
kick myself in the freaking nose because
I was always saying Bitcoin in all the
crypto is a story of confidence right
it's a confidence gate stores of value
are only worth things because we say
they are and gold's a confidence game
right now and we had just and we're in
the middle of the greatest glow
confidence kicking the gut that I've
ever seen right confidence is shaken in
institutions it's shaking in you like it
and it's just shaking our ability to
understand things and so that's why the
markets all sold off and it makes all
the sense in the world with hindsight
that crypto about the baby
I'm hoping the liquidation is a Bitcoin
are coming close to an end you know
we've had two big pukes and I'm guessing
a lot of the leverage is getting you
know squeezed out of the market real
quick and so I'd love to see Bitcoin for
instance stabilized
you know I'd love to see it closed over
5,000 and kind of stabilized even
between five and six thousand you know
for a while because they do things in
the long run the story doesn't go away
and why I don't think he goes to zero
ever there is a core group of developers
they don't care if the world's blowing
up they're still developing on it there
are most of the guys I know that own you
know kind of 10,000 plus coin positions
they haven't sold they don't plan on
selling these guys ready for the long
haul that's part of their portfolio and
so you know it's a damn shame you would
have felt a lot smarter to have sold a
lot of 10,000 and have firepower to be
buying it down here but but I don't I
don't see that so I'm hoping for Bitcoin
as you get stability it for all the
crypto and I think you're going to see
better opportunities literally in the
and some of the bombed out equity
markets
you
you
you with me the separation the question
then like what are you doing with your
portfolio right you said you weren't as
aggressive as you thought you wanted to
be but now that you kind of realize the
situation we're in how do you think
about maneuvering in these markets and
what exactly do you do to position
yourself well for some sort of recovery
you know at some point you know for the
for the first time in life I don't know
you know since I started crypto I would
I would now in this brief moment
considered myself a hot oiler I'm good
at you know I'm gonna hold our Bitcoin I
do think it comes back I believe it in
the long run I think it's you know
listen this was a test that I did it it
didn't look great and you know but I
think it's it didn't behave much
different than most of the other assets
that were risk assets and so it was it
imagined bullet by any stretch but I do
think the story continues and so you
know from investing perspective will
hold up hold a bit quit and listen
though they're there it's not like our
whole industries going away like I said
it's probably been set back 12 to 18
months in terms of people's excitement
to put new capital in it and so I do
think underneath outside of Bitcoin you
know the blockchain space itself
continues to grow you know more and more
companies are getting involved and so
the venture business around blockchain
continues to be interesting
I think the blockchain you know SAS or
consulting businesses are still busy and
so that technology shift is it isn't
gonna isn't going to change how that
translates in the markets and crypto and
us trading these queens as as a store
value or as a forward look on what will
come right if you think about a theory
of or any of the other protocol talk on
that they have some core value but they
really are more adventure bet on this
ecosystem being built that's still going
to happen it's just you're not going to
see the value in the coin until the
ecosystem really starts humming a little
bit
you
you with me and so you know one of my
arguments here is that to your point
about Bitcoin gold everything kind of
getting sold in this liquidity crisis if
you go back to 2008 gold sold off in the
six months so it's kind of over the
summer timeframe about 30% and then you
saw the quantitative easing and monetary
stimulus and then it ended the crisis up
about 3x from where it started the
crisis do you think there's a similar
thing that happens here with Bitcoin I
mean kind of that in the liquidity
crisis everything gets sold off but
Bitcoin and gold end up doing well over
the long term or do you think that that
confidence game plays into this much
more and we don't actually see that
listen I think it's gonna be so you know
fool me once smacked me fool me twice
you know I feel dumb
people bought gold and would have bought
Bitcoin back after away because you
believed in an inflationary impulse
right and it took a long time and so
we're gonna need this and we didn't
really get it we Roenick lee were just
starting to get some inflation not a lot
but we're just starting to before this
this virus hit us and so I mean I always
thought it was crazy that Trump was
running a 5% fiscal deficit while he had
full employment and low rates right it
was we were juicing the thing as much as
we could now you're gonna have a
deflationary impulse but you're gonna
have all the embers to see if you get
the fire going again I think the natural
inclination will be for gold to bounce
some maybe out 1,400 that would be my
targeting gold for the liquidations to
end and you know Bitcoin I hope we've
already hit below it you know 4000 or
4500 whatever the you want to call the
tradable low that that flashed hey that
will start going up I don't think it
will really accelerate until we actually
see you know the the basement of
currency I a real inflation you know
because people are bought into this
deflationary environment and this is a
big deflationary
we certainly might we're gonna see
unprecedented fiscal ready well it would
shock me if we go to at 8% fiscal
deficit right we're at five and God
forbid who knows what this is going to
cost us maybe it's a 10% fiscal deficit
any zero rates and a Fed monetizing and
so you'll have some people jump on that
here it comes
but I don't think you're really going to
see the acceleration of gold in or
Bitcoin until you see the inflation so
you can start smelling this you know the
fire pause
got it so I want to switch gears real
quick so I think that the economic stuff
is one half of this conversation but
then I know you're super into a number
of the social justice different
movements everything from kind of prison
reform to other aspects of social
justice maybe talk a little bit about
how you see the virus and the subsequent
economic slowdown affecting some of
those other initiatives that are kind of
outside of the finance yeah so this time
where this just capital a t-shirt that
my friend Paul Jones gave to me you know
he's the chairman of this group that has
been trying to tell this new story that
we really need multi-stakeholder
capitalism as opposed to just
shareholder value driven and that he put
a letter out it didn't really get well
read because we're in the middle of a
crises looked at the Russell 1000 and
you looked at there are 20 million
employees in the Russell 1000 and 10
million of the 20 million people make
less than the living wage and so the
letter was asking CEOs to look at their
own company and st. Jude hated people
better you know both with equity and
with compensation because those are your
those are your resources like and it was
co-written by the by the CEO of eBay
I'm sorry PayPal you know so
that kind of in mind and you're seeing
that in them in our politics right how
do we have a capitalism that actually
benefits more people this is just gonna
exacerbate that all of those workers are
gonna hurt a lot more than than you or I
will in an environment like this the
uncertainty feels worse the medical
bills could feel worse and so I do think
our politicians get that and you're
hearing it every time they're talking
we've got to take care of that you know
the people below but I you know as we
come out of this maybe it gives us a
chance to kind of look and say hey what
kind of capitalism do we want in our
country you know it's this the baby do
socialism and capitalism is kind of
horseshit you know what what the Center
has been pushing to if it's Larry Fink
or Jamie Dimon or Paul Jones or Marc
Andreessen all has been this
multi-stakeholder happened somewhere
capitalism got way too skewed to the to
the shareholder and how do you balance
that a little bit I've got four young
kids well not so young anymore but gen Z
Millennials and you know their whole
generation says this don't work from the
environment to the community you work
into your employee to your customer and
your shared well they kind of want that
balance and so I think you know this
little get lost a little of the crises
but hopefully coming out of this people
say hey how do we build something that
is a little more sustainable you know
then when it comes to the prison reform
stuff we're really really worried about
our prison populations getting Korona
you're stuck you know the exact reason
they say kids home from college right
because they don't want people stuck in
these dormitories you can transmit the
thing so quickly think about what a
prison is and think of the sanitary
conditions in a prison and so we have
been pushing and advocating for to start
with people not getting sent back to
prison for a technical parole violation
we have a shocking amount of people
right a million of quarter people a year
get sent back to prison for a technical
violation that means you've got a
speeding ticket while you you're out on
parole or your you've got an illegal
u-turn or you've showed up late for a
parole meeting and they send you back to
the to the can that makes absolutely no
sense it makes no sense any time but
especially in this environment where
you're putting someone and a whole
community at risk
same thing with pretrial right bail
reform you know until people are guilty
keep them out of the out of the prisons
and so you know we're pushing those
things people are looking at them you
know hopefully some of that gets done
but this virus in general any crises
always highly highlights the most
vulnerable people in society and you
know you're nervous BMI and you're
nervous in your and you got all the
resources in the planet than you think
[ __ ] if I'm nervous these resources
Howard the people with no resources and
so you know it's a I'm surprised the
government hasn't set up a charity
already where people can donate to you
know helping this gig economy world I
mean it's not just the gig economy I use
that as a but but the this group of
people that without their paychecks
coming in without their income coming in
are really going to feel the suffer you
know put George Bush and Bill Clinton in
charge or something like that or Obama
all right
yeah and I guess part of that really is
the one part is the actual workers
themselves in these small businesses but
then you've got the small business
entrepreneurs - right the people who own
those restaurants who own kind of these
non corporate or chain type businesses
how do they navigate this because it's
one thing for us to say hey we should
help pay these workers there's things
like charities there could be some
fiscal policy etc but if you're reliant
on a small business for your income and
your families kind of well-being and all
of a sudden the country goes into a two
three four week you know really just
stop what happens to those businesses
what can we do - yeah I think you're
gonna have to give them you know I mean
they're good they're gonna try SBA loans
you know so loans in or grants I mean
you think about your you run a sports
store and you sell Sporting Goods you
know if you're the local Main Street
sporting goods store and all of a sudden
you go with zero sales for two months
now there are a hundred examples I keep
thinking of the small restaurants and
it's thought that a Chinese restaurant
on the way back from the Hamptons
yesterday in one strip mall and yeah we
were the only people in there and I was
talking to the guys he at least had a
delivery hope but yeah I think this is
this is really going to be complicated
on how you get money into those
businesses and and you know and there's
got to be some sense of fairness on how
it happens you're not going to be
perfectly fair but you got to have some
blanket sense of fairness I made a
gallows you were joking
after Bitcoin went from whatever eight
thousand to four thousand that night if
Galaxie was able to get a small business
loan because we were we were becoming
smaller you know and that was a bad joke
maybe but the you know it's painful for
big businesses with payrolls and you
know because business is all businesses
are gonna slow down right let me tell
you there's a lot less
even if the trading business is going on
there's a lot less happening in in the
advisory business and the banking
business and you know talking to someone
about a new token no one was to talk
about anything right now about being
safe and you know or what's this virus
going so productivity collapses it so I
think all businesses are gonna have a
hard time we got to be really worried
about you know the small ones because
they they employ a ton of people and
that's where all our growth comes from
and B it's you know again they're in the
learn the more vulnerable place all
right buddy like grab my hat every time
I finish talking so one of the last
questions for you a lot of people now
are talking about mmt and kind of
helicopter me where your thoughts there
do we see it happen should we see it
happen just kind of maybe riff on that
you don't have a theta more of as a
version of ubi and I don't think it's a
terrible idea
if you gave everyone on the in the
country a thousand dollars you know a
month for three months right that's
that's a trillion dollars that's a
pretty big stimulus right there
it's fairly distributed if you want you
kind of cut out the rich people but
there's not enough rich people that it
really makes a big difference in the
number and so to kind of do it
consistently Hongkong did that
Australia's doing that that gives people
some spending money I don't believe in
mmt I do think it won't point if you
keep printing for any money you're gonna
get rip-roaring inflation you know I
just see it as an emerging market
investor my whole life you know it's a
it's a catchy way to justify it running
monster
you know fiscal deficits there's a thing
in economics called the Minsky moment
it's another confidence gig it's you're
okay until you're not and so there's
your the old curbs flat until it stands
on its head or there's no inflation
until it rips up
so you have this sense that well look
Japan has done it we can do it we're
running 5% deficits and the yield curve
is still low you know long bonds are
buck 35 you know we should be borrowing
more and more well at one point
confidence breaks it confidence as we
just saw with bitcoins a very fickle
game and so when if you lose confidence
in people's desire to hold long term
Treasuries game oh right
then we're in it we're going back to the
stone Age's or we're going into the
Bitcoin age and so you got to be pretty
careful when you swing around and then
tea as a as an ethos as a short-term fix
with Juby I make some sense right now he
have a hundred percent that's my hat to
tell you you can ask the question
got it and so lastly let's just wrap up
with you spent most of your career
or a good portion of your career trading
currencies and looking at these emerging
markets what are the things where you're
like hey let's avoid you know one two
and three or here's the warning signs
that people should be paying attention
to because I do think that you've got
kind of unique experience and seeing
kind of what not to do in some scenarios
so maybe share a little bit yes the
biggest mistake people make is when
kracie starts in a market breaks
everyone thinks oh it's time to get back
in way too early right and oh it's a
three station move it's time to buy end
you know time to buy the airlines it's
time to to sell [ __ ] always get gets
much worse than you think it's going to
get and so I tell myself I sometimes
make the same mistake but I tell myself
hey we got an instinct to buy something
going a long walk come back a week later
and look at it going a long walk come
back a week later and look at it and
it's usually worse off so once things
start going bad they they tend to stay
going bad for a while until you get a
real Zenith and so you know if it's you
know and you looked at dollar Brazil at
four it looked pretty good an ounce at
five you know and pick a story where the
fundamentals you know are turning
positive and serve America's markets
it's this it's the first derivative that
matters it's not the absolutes are
things getting better at the margin or
worse at the margin and so if you can
see things turning better at the margin
right that usually starts the cycle of
where things get better and so you know
that it doesn't mean you can buy
bombed-out things and sell them but what
you're really trying to do when there's
this evisceration is buy things that you
can hold for a long time look at you
know Churchill Downs Kentucky Derby
is a stock CH DN the thing went from 160
to 80 in the last six weeks
so 1/2 ounce they're gonna cancel the
Kentucky Derby they make about a hundred
million dollars a year on the Derby it
was a five billion dollar company so
you're like wait they're gonna lose 100
million of revenue one year and the
company is now worth half as much and so
companies like that you know you do your
homework you find that where the
fundamental value is then you can scale
in you don't have to even if jumps right
away you don't have to sell it and
you're like okay this is a real business
that's gonna so if it's if it's a
country that the country is on the right
footing if it's a business if the
businesses on the right footing and
don't go early
other businesses that you're looking at
the you're kind of salivating over and
saying hey I might want try to pipe yeah
we have this crypto business a appear
galaxy digital and then downstairs I
have a private equity business that I'm
a part owner of called the rational
capital and you know we've been looking
in the food space like people are gonna
have to keep eating and so there's some
there's some really interesting plays
and protein we've been looking at
putting big cattle to work in and I
looked like I got through the Kentucky
Derby out there I had been a big owner
of it two years ago with the hope that
maybe we could find some way to take the
private it was a ambitious idea we could
have made a whole lot of money on it
all right well Mike listen I appreciate
you you jumping on and doing this I know
especially given the chaos in the
markets and having to do it remotes
never as much fun as in person so what
they so much for doing this and let's do
it again in the future
Anthony hey thanks thanks a time